[Music]
how many of you guys uh have a nintendo
switch i have one
all right oh you guys want to link up
let's play them for animal crosstalk
i'm stuck in ps5 mode right now but sure
oh yeah you have a ps5 yeah i forgot
about that that was when i got kovid oh
where'd you put it i haven't seen your
ps5 it's uh in right next to my tv it
looks like you're making something up
right now
you're a [ __ ] liar that mannerism
right there one person at this table
that lies all the time i'll let you
guess which one it is
at that table
it ain't swinging joke this guy yeah you
look like a pure worker but you don't
work at the pierce nope i think between
me and you you're like you're a worker
yep you're no you're a fraud man
everyone knows you're too cool to be a
peer worker you know yeah you know
you're a long shoreman yeah
you're too stylish to do that [ __ ] man
long johns all right well for those of
you guys who have nintendo switches
i don't i don't know if you knew this
but
there was a a way you could hack your
switch do you remember that you could
hack it to play like pretty much oh yeah
really yeah i thought you could hack it
to play with the japanese versions of
games there's that you must be able to
deal with the psp you could also play a
game exactly yeah so basically somebody
developed a little did you say exactly
yeah he did and it was not it was fine
was that a pun over like
something i wasn't aware of
that really struck a chord with you the
best part is that we still opened up on
you
why it's too easy anyway you can uh you
could hack your switch to play all these
pirated games uh the guy who was
responsible for creating that
uh he was caught a while back
they finally got he's a canadian dude
they had to go to the dominican republic
to catch him oh [ __ ] so he
and it just so happens his name's gary
bowser
what if the manhunt is over that's ty
[ __ ]
the detective that got him is mario so
he was only one guy uh
like uh among a company of dudes that
were making these chips and selling them
and uh they were only able to catch him
the other two guys are like in countries
different countries that they don't
believe they'll be able to get him
because the countries won't extradite
him but they got this guy and obviously
when that happens you try to make an
example out of the guy that you did
catch
and because of that
the us government is seeking a five-year
prison sentence for this hacker gary
bowser in addition to a 14.5 million
dollar fine he already agreed to pay
what about the [ __ ] main
cabinets dude main cabinets are sick
well i mean i don't want that to happen
yeah yeah they're licensed my buddy
actually
i actually love your main camera thank
you
and he's gonna take it out already man
we just got it
come on my buddy and his brother was one
of the first people to license all those
games
okay and then um he he he actually has
you know those consoles like if you buy
a nintendo throwback right and then all
the games of nintendo's in those it's
like 30 of them it's not all of them
yeah it's not it's nowhere near what 34.
but there's one of them that has
hundreds of like if it's a sega genesis
one or the soldier boy one probably
once they sell at the kiosk at the mall
those ones no no the they're just
they're distribution remember
whatever happened with that i think i
think it went under yeah
what's the soldier boy console throwing
it on console man yeah it's called
soldier we talked about north korea yeah
oh really yeah yeah yeah he forgot
tanked but yeah so the one that you're
talking about is legal yeah because they
they were the first to license that
stuff dude he made [ __ ] crazy money
on it but like when you started seeing
all the throwback games all in one
console that was their company have you
guys ever had a pirated like console or
anything like that or like a black fox
girl china friends rat you out
[Laughter]
do you remember the i was just talking
about man the the japanese nintendo
where if you [ __ ] nail filed the side
you could play uh super nintendo games
and [ __ ] or like i didn't know about
that
famicom it was like top loading or yeah
something like that dude growing up my
dad he would go to china sometimes so he
bought a ps2 in china
and it was pirated so you buy all these
pirated games
bring it back and we would have all
these crazy cheap games that we weren't
able to play in the us but the
playstation would work like half the
time it just would like you it would
sometimes when it worked you'd be like
oh [ __ ] i get to play all these games
but then most of the time it was a total
[ __ ] complete piece do you guys
remember pokemon stadium yeah dude so
when that game came out it actually came
out like i think 10 months before in
japan and so my dad went to like this
store in l.a that had like japanese
imported games he actually brought home
like this little converter thing and the
game so we were able to play pokemon
snap but in japanese it was the most
confusing [ __ ] ever because all of it
has to be like you gotta get
yeah i was like stressed out kid i was
like and the name puns just weren't
hitting with you i was like i don't know
how to use solar beam how do i use sword
which one is it it's a guessing game at
that point yeah it was really hard and i
was always jealous of my chinese friends
because they had all the [ __ ] bootleg
[ __ ] dude like stuff was dope it didn't
make a difference to kids man back then
and it was it was funny too because you
could you could put your um game boy
like pokedex into the the nintendo 64
cartridge
but then it was like i was seeing my
venusaur in the game yeah even though it
was just the same sprite every other kid
saw but i was like that's mine
it's his name it's my being short he's
the level that i've gone to
it's true though it is the level you
want to yeah i did earn them
but yeah this uh so the the grounds for
that lawsuit they're basically gonna you
know any time that you
uh mess with intellectual property of
anything tech they have a really great
way of calculating the what the loss is
on their end for that
you know what i mean so if you think of
that like anything that he pirate or all
the possible people that might have used
this chip and played pirated games
they're just going to total all that up
the way that napster got hit when people
downloaded music you know so um
yeah but then this guy bowser he only
claims that he made 320 000 over the
seven years
that he was uh doing this yet his fine
is just like astronomical how the hell
is he supposed to pay stuff like that
i don't believe him though he probably
won't yeah especially if he's a canadian
dude who now lives in the dominican
republic and his two other accomplices
are in other countries with no
extradition how much did he put into
crypto that's well true
maybe if he's a tech dude
yeah but he's yeah he's a 50 he's a 51
year old guy and yeah he was arrested
yeah and he's in his 50s so he's had
time to do this plus
plus he's agreed to the 14 million
dollar fine that's true if he only made
300 000 and he's agreeing to 14 million
fool's balling somehow he's balling
somewhere for sure but nintendo's
definitely not the company to mess with
they're like the hardest when it comes
to coming after their ip street making
it really [ __ ] hard for streamers yep
can't even do it in terms of you guys
see the history of nintendo it's pretty
gangster
they were a gambling den the card the
cinco was like chickens right there was
like little playing cards and [ __ ] like
that gambling all that and it came into
[ __ ] this whole video game empire
shigeru miyamoto is like a [ __ ]
genius though like the fact that he came
up with mario he came up with [ __ ]
zelda he came up with like samus and all
that [ __ ] the framework of all games
today just like all of it
wasn't he like a janitor or some [ __ ] um
he was like a low-level dude in the in
the game in the uh in the company and he
just kept saying like no we got to try
these other games because they were
trying to compete with pong
and then the top heads were like now we
gotta we gotta do this [ __ ] to make our
own he's like a good will hunting
janitor where they just left the board
out and he solves the math formula best
characters through a plumber who did
this
she plumbers
yeah so uh he's up for a lot of [ __ ] in
his life this guy but it sucks because
most of the time when people figure
things out like this like the switch is
notoriously difficult to crack and the
guy did it and uh so he should get paid
for it yeah exactly sometimes you're
hoping they'll just hire the dude that's
what usually happens right when a hacker
like hacks the thing they get that's
like whoa that's a great resume come
over to the company i think that's the
smart thing to do yeah right that's what
uh that's what the the tarot blockchain
was doing right where they were like
willing to pay a million dollars to any
hacker who could find a bug in their
protocols because they wanted to be you
know hacker proof yeah then you
basically just turn them into a white
hat just exactly in one day you host a
hackathon you you book a house in miami
you have everybody come out they all sit
there
really they all sit there with laptops
and like just [ __ ] chill together
people are in town in la this week for
both an ethereum and a solana blockchain
hackathon no way so it's a refinement
and somebody successfully hacked solana
because [ __ ] 230 million dollars got
taken out of wormhole the other day yeah
that's crazy crazy
yeah so the federal court's going to
figure out how much time he has to do uh
people are really trying to advocate for
me do less because five years i mean
that that's a pretty long sentence for
something that's non-violent i guess
it's more of like a corporate crime and
there's a lot of big-ass [ __ ] going on
the world people are not even getting
close to that
uh but yeah his his uh 14.5 million
dollar uh payout is actually 4.5 million
is his actual fine for what he did going
to the federal the 10 million is going
straight to nintendo as a civil lawsuit
would you rather if it was one or the
other
pay 14.5 million or do five years in
prison
i don't even got 14 million five years i
would just honestly take the fine and
just default on my [ __ ] payment like
everybody else [ __ ] does well no they
don't bail you out though they don't be
able to like us out sorry oh damn like
us no we don't get bailed out can i
still buy this guy's a rig you can
actually i can't yeah but that's not you
i don't even know if you can legally
even it's like one of those things where
like the so the um like nintendo made it
so that if you even talk about where to
find an illegal game file on a website
your whole site could be just taken down
they could sue you for that they could
sue you for even naming the source i got
a question this has a hacker right yeah
i just use a vpn
duh
and that brings us to our ad
he's a [ __ ] idiot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you